نحن سالنا الناس في السعوديه هل ستدفع
لتوثق حسابك على تويتر بالاجابه سلام
والله انا صراحه
التوثيق ما له علاقه بالدفع ارى لا يكون
في دفع في التوثيق يعني
والله ماني مهتم لتوثيق وكذا يعني
اتابع تويتر بس بدون ما واثق حسابي وكذا
صراحه انا شخص يعني انا ادخل تويتر برنامج
تويتر كثير بس ما ماني مهتم اني ادفع فلوس
عشان التوثيق والله اذا كان عندي محتوى ما
راح ادفع اكيد انه بيتوثق اذا ما عندي
محتوى بدفع
وانا ما عندك محتوى تبغى حسابك وعندك قدره
ماليه اكيد متوثق حسابك عن طريق قدره
الماليه
[موسيقى]
ليش ادفع علشان
اوثق حسابي
المفترض اني ما ادفع لا انا متابع في
تويتر وليس ادفع في ناس يدفعون
عشان يصير محتواها من اكثر لاكثر انا
انسان متابع بس لا الصراحه
يعني ما احس انه شيء حلو وغير كذا انه انا
قاعده اشوف اللي يسوى واللي ما يسوى قاعد
يوثق حسابه
احس انه بس تجميع متابعيني على الفاضي
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات